good evening first to His Highness
Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum
and to my good friend sunny Varkey and
all of you gathered to celebrate the
finalists of the global teacher prize I
wish I could be with you again in person
the lessons that come from great
teachers stay with us long after
students leave the classroom I still
remember my favorite teachers from grade
school and high school I wrote about
them in my memoirs what I learned and
the experience and inspiration they
provided someone once asked me if I
really did remember all their names and
I went through the whole list right from
memory that's how important my teachers
were in my life I'll never forget them a
year ago I stood where you are tonight
with the finalists of the inaugural
global teacher prize when I stood on
that stage with those 10 remarkable
teachers I couldn't help but think about
all the lives they touched in their
careers
all the doors they'd open all the minds
they'd fired I also thought about how
they represented so many many teachers
all around the world whose devoted work
every single day is a profound
investment in our shared future so I
congratulate the 2016 finalists I thank
all of you for the dedication you have
shown and the lives you've lifted you
don't hear it often enough but your work
is truly heroic